This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. How should we live? What will make us happy? How can each of us become the person we want to be? In our modern world, there are all kinds of people eager to provide us with answers to these questions. Mental health gurus, self-help authors, social media influencers, even the researchers we feature on the show.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们该如何生活？什么会让我们幸福？我们每个人如何才能成为自己想成为的人？在现代世界，有各种各样的人渴望为我们提供这些问题的答案。心理健康大师、自助书籍作者、社交媒体网红，甚至是我们节目中介绍的研究人员。
But there is an important mistake we make when we seek out such counselors. We usually look to sources of wisdom that are around us. We assume the most valuable answers to our questions must come from people who happen to inhabit the planet at the same time that we do. habit the planet at the same time that we do. But humans have wrestled with the same questions about relationships, purpose and identity for thousands of years. Wouldn't the wisest people who lived centuries ago have useful things to say about our modern dilemmas? This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion piece on our subscription feed Hidden Brain
但我们在寻找这些导师时犯了一个重要的错误。我们通常会向周围的智慧源泉寻求答案。我们认为，关于我们问题的最有价值的答案，一定来自那些恰好与我们生活在同一时代的人。但几千年来，人类一直在纠结于关于关系、目标和身份的相同问题。那些几个世纪前生活过的最睿智的人，难道对我们现代的困境就没有什么有用的见解吗？本周在《隐藏的大脑》以及我们订阅源中的配套节目《隐藏的大脑》中
Plus, we explore the insights of five great thinkers from ancient Greece. Decades of research reveal that our actions don't always match our intentions. We plan to reach out to a friend who's sick or we resolve to start a new exercise program. And then we don't. Be fatdled and surprised, we try again. And fall short again. Psychologists have come up with a number of explanations for this gap between our intentions and our actions and what we can do to close it.
此外，我们还将探索古希腊五位伟大思想家的见解。几十年的研究表明，我们的行动并不总是与我们的意图相符。我们计划去探望一位生病的朋友，或者我们下定决心开始一项新的锻炼计划。然后我们却没有去做。我们感到困惑和惊讶，我们再次尝试。然后再次失败。心理学家们对这种意图与行动之间的差距，以及我们如何弥合这一差距，提出了许多解释。
At Yale University, the philosopher Tamar Gendler says questions like this also animated a thinker in ancient Greece. The highest wisdom and our greatest challenge, he argued, is to know ourselves. Tamar Gendler, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, I'm delighted to be here. So Tomar, Socrates famously said that the unexamined life is not worth living. Can you set the stage for me by describing who this man was
在耶鲁大学，哲学家塔玛·根德勒说，这样的问题也曾激发过古希腊的一位思想家。他认为，最高的智慧和我们最大的挑战，就是认识我们自己。塔玛·根德勒，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，很高兴来到这里。那么塔玛，苏格拉底曾有名言说，未经审视的生活是不值得过的。你能通过描述这个人是谁来为我铺垫一下吗？
and how he came to wrestle with some of the same questions that we wrestle with today? Socrates lived about 2, hundred years ago in ancient Athens and he was kind of like a provocative podcaster. He hung out in what was the most technologically advanced location of the time. That is, he hung out in a place called the Agora, which was the public square. And as people passed him by, he asked them questions that caused them to examine their fundamental beliefs. And eventually, he developed a following of some of the young men of Athens, who were associated with the most powerful families.
以及他是如何开始纠结于我们今天所纠结的一些相同问题的？苏格拉底生活在约2500年前的古雅典，他就像一个挑衅性的播客主持人。他经常出没于当时技术最先进的地方。也就是说，他经常出没于一个叫“阿哥拉”的地方，也就是公共广场。当人们从他身边经过时，他会问他们一些问题，促使他们审视自己的基本信念。最终，他吸引了一批雅典的年轻人，他们大多与最有权势的家族有关联。
And he spoke to those young men and he asked them to think in a very fundamental way about which of the values that they had been taught were values to which they were reflectively committed and which of them were just coincidental features of their society. That is, really, were the things that they had been taught are just, just. Were the things that they had been taught are pious, pious. Were the things that they had been taught about the God's true? And were the families of these kids excited that they were learning from this wise man or
他与那些年轻人交谈，并要求他们以一种非常根本的方式思考：他们被教导的价值观中，哪些是他们经过反思后所认同的，而哪些仅仅是他们社会中偶然存在的特征。也就是说，他们被教导的事情真的是虔诚的吗？他们被教导的关于神的那些事情是真的吗？这些孩子的家庭是否为他们能从这位智者那里学习而感到兴奋，还是
were they horrified. The families of these children, remember, are the individuals who are in the primary power structure of Athens, for whom belief in tradition is crucial for sustaining their regime. So they are in fact extraordinarily upset by what Socrates is doing to their kids. So upset that they actually put him on trial with the accusation that he has violated the laws of the city by corrupting the youth. And ultimately, Socrates is actually convicted by an Athenian jury of having corrupted the youth, is given the penalty of death by the drinking of poison, and makes his final lesson for his students by obeying the laws of the city and taking his life in accord with the city's mandate
他们感到惊恐？请记住，这些孩子的家庭是雅典主要权力结构中的成员，对他们来说，信仰传统对于维持他们的政权至关重要。所以，他们实际上对苏格拉底对他们的孩子所做的事情感到异常愤怒。愤怒到他们竟然以腐蚀青年的罪名将他送上法庭。最终，苏格拉底被雅典陪审团判决腐蚀青年罪名成立，被判处饮毒酒自尽，他通过服从城市法律并按照城市的指令结束自己的生命，为他的学生上了最后一课
that he'd be punished by death for corruption of the youth. So he really was committed to the deep truth of what he aimed to teach so much so that he was willing to give his life for it. Did Socrates or any of his students question the justice of the sentence that was handed down to him? Absolutely. And there's an extraordinarily moving story of Socrates' students trying to persuade him to resist this death sentence, and of Socrates' responding that he needs to exceed to the laws of the city in which he has been nurtured and grown. So, during the trial of Socrates, one of his students visits the oracle at Delphi, and
即他因腐蚀青年而被判处死刑。所以他确实非常忠于他旨在传授的深刻真理，以至于他愿意为此献出生命。苏格拉底或他的任何学生是否质疑过对他作出的判决的公正性？当然。有一个非常感人的故事，讲的是苏格拉底的学生试图说服他反抗这个死刑判决，而苏格拉底回应说，他需要服从他所成长和生活的城市的法律。所以，在苏格拉底受审期间，他的一名学生拜访了德尔斐的神谕，并且
the student has a question for the oracle. What is the question to him? The student visits the oracle at Delphi, which is a mystical place where truth is available and asks the oracle, who is the wisest of all men? And the oracle answers in a very perplexing way. The oracle says, no man is wiser than Socrates. So the student comes back from the oracle to bear this news to Socrates and Socrates says, how could it be that I am considered the wisest of all men?
那个学生向神谕提出了一个问题。对他来说这个问题是什么？学生拜访了德尔斐的神谕，那是一个可以获得真理的神秘之地，并问神谕，谁是所有人中最睿智的？神谕以一种非常令人困惑的方式回答。神谕说，没有人比苏格拉底更睿智。所以学生从神谕那里回来，把这个消息告诉苏格拉底，苏格拉底说，我怎么可能被认为是所有人中最睿智的呢？
For I know nothing and recognize that I know nothing, whereas others who also know nothing falsely think that they know. Now, Socrates was a pretty smart guy and he must have known he was a pretty smart guy. So it's he being falsely modest here. I mean, what aspect of the world is Socrates not know about that he says that I know nothing? What is he referring to here tomorrow? Even if Socrates is being falsely modest when he says, I know that I know nothing, he is also saying knowing the limits of your knowledge is essential to understanding the
因为我一无所知，并且承认我一无所知，而其他人虽然也一无所知，却错误地认为自己知道。现在，苏格拉底是个相当聪明的人，他一定知道自己很聪明。所以他是在这里假装谦虚吗？我的意思是，苏格拉底说我一无所知，他指的是世界上哪方面的知识？塔玛，他在这里指的是什么？即使苏格拉底在说“我知道我一无所知”时是假装谦虚，他也是在说，了解你知识的局限性对于理解
limits of human understanding. One of the really crucial things that Socrates recognizes is that he has neither a full understanding of the world outside of him, nor does he have a full understanding of the world inside of him, a full understanding of his own thoughts and motivations. So partly what he's describing here is not just a description of his own state of knowledge, but about the difficulty of acquiring that knowledge, the fact that when he looks inside, he in fact is not completely aware of his own motivations and drives. I would say it is both a factual descriptive claim and a more profound claim about the nature of knowledge. So an important thing to understand about the picture of the world that Socrates holds
人类认知的局限性至关重要。苏格拉底认识到的一个非常关键的事情是，他既没有对身外的世界有完全的理解，也没有对身内的世界有完全的理解，没有对自己思想和动机的完全理解。所以他在这里描述的部分内容，不仅是对他自身知识状态的描述，更是关于获取那种知识的难度，即当他向内看时，他实际上并不完全了解自己的动机和驱动力。我会说这既是一个事实性的描述性主张，也是一个关于知识本质的更深刻的主张。所以，理解苏格拉底所持有的世界观的一个重要点是
is that human beings themselves are subject not only to the general constraint that as imperfect concrete earthly beings, we can't know anything fully true and fully good. But in addition, human beings are particularly complicated objects for human beings to understand. So the suggestion is not just that he discovers that he doesn't know his motivations and he doesn't know all the internal features of himself. It's that in addition, he has a proof, a reason to think that that is impossible. You know, I feel that there are literally hundreds
人类自身不仅受到一般的限制，即作为不完美的、具体的、世俗的存在，我们无法完全了解任何完全真实和完全美好的事物。而且，人类对于人类来说是特别复杂的对象。所以，这不仅仅是他发现自己不知道自己的动机，也不知道自己内部的所有特征。而是此外，他有一个证据，一个理由认为这是不可能的。你知道，我感觉实际上有数百个
of modern psychological experiments that back up this idea tomorrow. Political partisans seem to have no awareness that their loyalty, shape, what they hear and how they think. Biasis, pervert how we think about race or gender, but we are not always aware that we have these biases. And in our relationships, people fall into unconscious patterns of behavior in ways that are really damaging to those relationships.
现代心理学实验支持这个观点，塔玛。政治党派人士似乎完全没有意识到他们的忠诚如何塑造了他们的所听所想。偏见扭曲了我们对种族或性别的看法，但我们并不总是意识到我们有这些偏见。而在我们的关系中，人们会以真正损害这些关系的方式陷入无意识的行为模式。
I mean, all of these examples and the context might be very different from ancient Greece, but Socrates was interested in some of the same underlying questions here. In my classes, I often juxtapose this secratic tradition with the big question of social psychology of the 20th century, and in many ways of the 21st century as well, which is a scientific demonstration of the dissociation between apparent motivation and actual explanation of a particular kind of behavior. Over and over and over again, the lesson of contemporary social psychology is that we are opaque to ourselves with regard to why it is we are doing or experiencing what we are doing or
我的意思是，所有这些例子和背景可能与古希腊非常不同，但苏格拉底在这里关注的是一些相同的潜在问题。在我的课堂上，我经常将这种苏格拉底传统与20世纪，以及在许多方面也是21世纪社会心理学的一个大问题并列，那就是对表象动机与特定行为的实际解释之间脱节的科学证明。当代社会心理学的教训一遍又一遍地告诉我们，关于我们为什么在做或经历我们正在做或
experiencing. In her work, Tamara draws connections not only between ancient philosophers and modern social scientists, but themes that have animated writers for many centuries. For example, she cites the novel Anna Karenina by the Russian author Leo Tolstoy. Which is a book about the ways in which characters don't realize that their perception of the world is shaped through their individual mood.
经历的事情，我们对自己是不透明的。在她的工作中，塔玛不仅在古代哲学家和现代社会科学家之间建立了联系，还联系了许多世纪以来一直激励着作家的主题。例如，她引用了俄罗斯作家列夫·托尔斯泰的小说《安娜·卡列尼娜》。这是一本关于角色们没有意识到他们对世界的感知是如何被他们个人的情绪所塑造的书。
There's a beautiful moment where a character named Levin has fallen in love with a young woman named Kitty, and he walks around the world and he can only recognize how beautiful the world is. And he takes it to be a fact about the world that the world is beautiful. There's a subsequent scene where the main character Anna is dismayed about a fact in her life, and she walks around the world and she perceives the world as being filled with individuals who are ugly and mean. This is not unique to Anna Karenina.
有一个美丽的时刻，一个叫列文的角色爱上了一个叫吉蒂的年轻女子，他走在世界上，只能感受到世界是多么美丽。他认为世界是美丽的，这是关于世界的一个事实。随后有一个场景，主角安娜对她生活中的一个事实感到沮丧，她走在世界上，她感知到的世界充满了丑陋和刻薄的人。这并非《安娜·卡列尼娜》所独有。
Every single novel is about the ways in which characters fail to recognize their own motivations. And so I would say those are three examples, the stochratic example, the example of literature and the sociological example of 20th century empirical psychology, all of which are exploring in incredibly rich ways. The fact that human beings do not know themselves. So you suggest that we can try and derive self-knowledge by engaging in the kind of socratic dialogue that Socrates himself engaged in with his students. How would that work tomorrow?
每一部小说都是关于角色们未能认识到自己动机的方式。所以我会说这是三个例子，苏格拉底的例子、文学的例子和20世纪经验心理学的社会学例子，所有这些都在以极其丰富的方式探索一个事实，即人类并不了解自己。那么你建议我们可以通过参与苏格拉底本人与学生进行的那种苏格拉底式对话来尝试获得自我知识。塔玛，那会如何运作呢？
Socrates basically is willing to ask why repeatedly. So an inner-circadic dialogue involves being ready to reflect at any moment, why do I think that on what evidence is my judgment based for what reason am I pursuing this action? So in many ways, what Socrates is asking us to do is to engage in a process of inner reflection. At any moment, being ready with fully open mind to ask ourselves why we think, what we think, or why we are doing, what we are doing. So in other words, am I really in love with this person? Am I really happier when I make lots of money? Am I just absorbing what the culture is telling me,, am I really in love with this person? Am I really happier when I make lots of money?
苏格拉底基本上愿意反复询问“为什么”。所以，一场苏格拉底式的内心对话涉及随时准备反思：我为什么这么想？我的判断基于什么证据？我出于什么理由在追求这个行动？所以在许多方面，苏格拉底要求我们做的是参与一个内心反思的过程。在任何时刻，都准备好以完全开放的心态问自己，为什么我们这样想，或者为什么我们在做我们正在做的事情。所以换句话说，我真的爱这个人吗？当我赚很多钱时，我真的更快乐吗？我只是在吸收文化告诉我的东西吗？我真的爱这个人吗？当我赚很多钱时，我真的更快乐吗？
Am I just absorbing what the culture is telling me? Or do I really believe this? So those are big questions, and you could certainly apply the Socratic technique to that. But you could use it, why did I open the fridge? Am I bored? Am I hungry? Am I low on electrolytes?
我只是在吸收文化告诉我的东西吗？或者我真的相信这一点吗？所以这些都是大问题，你当然可以将苏格拉底式的方法应用于此。但你也可以使用它，我为什么要打开冰箱？我是无聊吗？我是饿了吗？我电解质不足吗？
You could ask the question, why did I pick up electrolytes? You could ask the question, why did I pick up my phone? You could ask the question, why am I feeling irritated right now? Are my socks wet? Or is the world full of injustice to which I am appropriately sensitive? So yes, you want to ask questions, do I really want to make money? And you also want to ask questions like, why did I open the fridge? Socrates taught us that self-knowledge is the foundation for human flourishing, but one of his students pointed out a complication.
你可以问这个问题，我为什么要拿起电解质？你可以问这个问题，我为什么要拿起手机？你可以问这个问题，我为什么现在感到烦躁？是我的袜子湿了吗？还是这个世界充满了我不公正地敏感对待的不公？所以是的，你想问问题，我真的想赚钱吗？你也想问像“我为什么要打开冰箱”这样的问题。苏格拉底教导我们，自我知识是人类繁荣的基础，但他的一个学生指出了一个复杂之处。
We don't just have one self inside ourselves, we have many. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Philosopher Tamar Gendler has spent decades studying ancient philosophers like Socrates, who emphasized the importance of knowing oneself. Socrates had a very smart student named Plato. He pointed out, there isn't one singular self for us to get to know. In fact, we have many selves inside us.
我们内心不仅仅有一个自我，我们有许多个。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。哲学家塔玛·根德勒花了数十年时间研究像苏格拉底这样的古代哲学家，他们强调认识自己的重要性。苏格拉底有一个非常聪明的学生叫柏拉图。他指出，我们并没有一个单一的自我可以去了解。事实上，我们内心有许多个自我。
Tamar, I understand that you have personally experienced the reality of a divided self when it comes to the subject of shoes. Tell me more. I am somebody who is a great appreciator of the capacity to bring joy and beauty to one's life through self ornamentation, particularly with regard to the adornment of one's feet. That is a fancy way of saying, I love buying used designer shoes on the internet. I am, however, not always able to tell whether a shoe will fit me. And consequently, a certain portion of the time, I need to return those shoes.
塔玛，我了解到你在鞋子的问题上亲身体验过分裂自我的现实。多告诉我一些。我是一个非常欣赏通过自我装饰，特别是通过装饰双脚来为生活带来快乐和美感的人。这是一种花哨的说法，我喜欢在网上买二手的名牌鞋。然而，我并不总是能判断一双鞋是否合脚。因此，在一定比例的情况下，我需要退掉那些鞋子。
One of the things that stuns me is right now, in the back of my car, is a box of shoes to be returned, which have been there with the label taped to them for the last two weeks. I have been unable to bring myself to mail these shoes back. Yeah. So, is this divided self, the divided self that says, I need to do something, but I don't have the time or willingness or motivation to do it.
让我震惊的一件事是，现在，在我的车后座上，有一盒要退掉的鞋子，标签贴在上面已经两周了。我一直无法让自己把这些鞋子寄回去。是的。所以，这是分裂的自我吗？那个说“我需要做某事，但我没有时间、意愿或动力去做”的分裂自我。
Or is this divided self an example of, I think I should return these shoes, but there's another part of me that says, I want to keep these shoes. In this particular case, it is all of me rationally that thinks I want to return these shoes. And then part of me that engages in what my friend,
还是这个分裂的自我是一个例子，即“我认为我应该退掉这些鞋子，但我的另一部分说，我想留着这些鞋子”。在这个特定的案例中，我理性地认为我想退掉这些鞋子，而我的一部分参与了我朋友
Laurie Santos, has taught me to understand as a bliger rebellion, that is, it is fun not to do a thing that I am supposed to be doing. The shoes don't fit. I need to return them by a certain deadline. If I return them, the money that I spent on them will be refunded to me in such a way that I can buy shoes or use it in some much more useful way. But within me, in addition to the fully endorsed desire to return those shoes, there is a certain amount of pleasure that attaches to simply not doing. What I reflectively know is the right thing for me to do.
劳里·桑托斯教我理解的“义务反叛”，也就是说，不做我应该做的事情是很有趣的。鞋子不合脚。我需要在某个截止日期前退掉它们。如果我退掉它们，我花在它们身上的钱会以某种方式退还给我，这样我就可以买鞋子或以更有用的方式使用它。但在我内心，除了完全认可退掉这些鞋子的愿望之外，还有一定程度的快乐附着在仅仅“不做”我反思后知道是正确的事情上。
I'm wondering if there are other dimensions of your life tomorrow, where you again feel like you have these two cells inside you that are at war with each other? At almost every moment, all of us have multiple sides of ourselves that are at war with each other. When I am exercising in the gym, there's a part of me that thinks, keep going forward, and a part of me that thinks, I'm exhausted, I'm just going to sit down, I don't feel like working any harder. When I need to get somewhere at a particular time, there's a part of me that knows
塔玛，我想知道你的生活中是否还有其他维度，让你再次觉得你有这两个在交战的自我？几乎在每一刻，我们所有人都有多个在交战的自我。当我在健身房锻炼时，我的一部分认为“继续前进”，而另一部分认为“我精疲力竭了，我只想坐下来，我不想再努力了”。当我在特定时间需要去某个地方时，我的一部分知道
if I need to be somewhere by one o'clock, then presumably I need to leave where I am sometime before one o'clock. But that's also a part of me that has this incoherent fantasy that I can leave the place where I am at one and be at the place where I'm going at one. You know Freud has this wonderful description that all of us have a part of ourselves that
如果我需要在一点钟前到达某个地方，那么大概我需要在一点钟之前离开我现在的地方。但那也是我的一部分，它有一种不连贯的幻想，认为我可以在一点钟离开我现在的地方，并在一点钟到达我要去的地方。你知道弗洛伊德有一个精彩的描述，即我们所有人都有自己的一部分
is infantile and inconsistent. Where we want things that are mutually inconsistent or we believe things that are mutually inconsistent, that is just deeply true of all of us and that part of ourselves just never goes away. And that's the part of you that thinks you can have your cake and eat it too, that things that are actually reflectively impossible could just happen. So Plato was one of the ancients who started to think about the phenomenon of the divide itself. What was his story, Tamara?
是幼稚且不一致的。我们想要相互矛盾的东西，或者我们相信相互矛盾的东西，这对我们所有人来说都是深刻的真实，而我们自己的那一部分永远不会消失。那就是你认为你可以鱼和熊掌兼得的那一部分，认为实际上反思后不可能的事情可能会发生。所以柏拉图是开始思考分裂自我现象的古人之一。塔玛，他的故事是什么？
So Plato was a philosopher who lived in ancient Greece, also about 2,500 years ago. He was a student of Socrates, and Plato was responsible for writing down a large set of philosophical dialogues that explored almost any question that was available at the time when he lived. What's the nature of justice? What's the nature of truth? What is the nature of the divine? How should a society be structured?
所以柏拉图是一位生活在古希腊的哲学家，也是大约2500年前。他是苏格拉底的学生，柏拉图负责写下了一大套哲学对话，探索了在他生活的那个时代几乎所有可用的问题。正义的本质是什么？真理的本质是什么？神圣的本质是什么？社会应该如何构建？
What should education look like? What is it to wage war? For any of the big questions about the individual or society, Plato wrote what is basically a play, where the main character was his teacher Socrates, and Socrates would engage in conversations about these questions with various imaginary and real young men. So Plato observes that we not only have multiple selves, but that these cells are often set against each other, that we are a house divided.
教育应该是什么样子？什么是发动战争？对于关于个人或社会的任何大问题，柏拉图写了基本上是一出戏，主角是他的老师苏格拉底，苏格拉底会与各种虚构和真实的年轻人就这些问题进行对话。所以柏拉图观察到，我们不仅有多个自我，而且这些自我往往是相互对立的，我们是一个分裂的家庭。
Plato tells a story that's basically my story of not returning the shoes, or the story of somebody who is rubber-necking on the highway when they pass an accident. So the story that Plato tells is that there's a man, his name happens to be Leontius, and he's walking back to the city of Athens, and he notices along the wall of the city a dead man lying on the ground in a really gross way. And Leontius struggles with himself in the way that you might, if you were driving
柏拉图讲了一个故事，基本上就是我不退鞋的故事，或者是一个人在高速公路上经过事故时伸长脖子看的故事。所以柏拉图讲的故事是，有一个人，他的名字叫莱昂提乌斯，他正走回雅典城，他注意到沿着城墙有一个死人以一种非常恶心的方式躺在地上。莱昂提乌斯像你开车时那样与自己斗争
past a car accident, and Leontius says to himself, don't look at that, that's disgusting. What are you doing? And then Leontius turns his face towards the dead body, holds his eyes open, and says, take a look at that beautiful sight you load some creatures. That is, he gives into his temptation. And you might imagine a similar story, which is opening the refrigerator and saying to yourself, I'm not going to eat the cake. I'm not going to eat the cake and then just giving into your temptation. So Plato tells this story of Laontius, which is the story of
经过车祸，莱昂提乌斯对自己说，别看那个，太恶心了。你在做什么？然后莱昂提乌斯把脸转向尸体，睁大眼睛，说，看看那个美丽的景象，你这讨厌的生物。也就是说，他屈服于自己的诱惑。你可以想象一个类似的故事，那就是打开冰箱对自己说，我不吃蛋糕。我不吃蛋糕，然后就屈服于你的诱惑。所以柏拉图讲了这个莱昂提乌斯的故事，这就是
eating the cake in the fridge, which is the story of rubber necking, which is the story of me not returning the shoes. In order to establish a picture that he has of what human beings are like, and the picture that he ends up introducing is that he says the human soul is, and by soul he just means the human mind. So the human soul says Plato in the translation that's most common, is composed of three parts. There's a part that he calls reason, there's a part that he calls spirit, and there's a part that he calls appetite. And how do these three relate to one another tomorrow?
吃冰箱里的蛋糕的故事，这就是伸长脖子看的故事，这就是我不退鞋的故事。为了建立他所拥有的关于人类是什么样子的图景，他最终引入的图景是，他说人类的灵魂是——而灵魂他指的就是人类的心智。所以柏拉图在最常见的翻译中说，人类的灵魂由三个部分组成。有一个他称之为理性的部分，有一个他称之为激情的（精神的）部分，有一个他称之为欲望的部分。塔玛，这三者是如何相互关联的？
So the part of the soul that he calls reason, played a likeness to the driver of a chariot. And that's the part of you that's rational and easily available to introspection. Reason is the stories that you tell yourself and the parts of yourself that are in keeping with your reflective commitments. But says Plato, Reason is only a small part of the human being. Reason is driving a chariot that is pulled by two horses, and he calls those horses Spirit and Apatite. The horse that he calls Spirit is responsive to social norms and social approval. That is, the spirited part of yourself is worried about things like
所以他称之为理性的灵魂部分，柏拉图将其比作战车的驾驶员。那是你理性且容易进行内省的部分。理性是你告诉自己的故事，以及你符合反思承诺的那部分自我。但柏拉图说，理性只是人类的一小部分。理性驾驶着一辆由两匹马牵引的战车，他称那些马为“激情”和“欲望”。他称之为“激情”的马对社会规范和社会认可做出反应。也就是说，你那充满激情的部分担心诸如
FOMO and what people think of you and what it's like to be in love and admired and all of the things that we care about in our social interactions. And the third part of yourself, what Plato calls the Apetitive Horse, is basically concerned with the parts of you that you share with non-human animals. Basically, the things that are required for survival and procreation, that is food and sex. So says Plato, think of yourself as having three parts, a part that you share with non-human animals that's full of appetites, four things like procreation
错失恐惧症（FOMO）、别人怎么看你、恋爱和被钦佩的感觉，以及我们在社交互动中关心的所有事情。而你自我的第三部分，柏拉图称之为“欲望之马”，基本上关注的是你与非人类动物共享的部分。基本上是生存和繁衍所需的东西，也就是食物和性。所以柏拉图说，认为自己有三个部分，一个你与非人类动物共享的、充满欲望的部分，用于繁衍
and consumption, a part of you that's concerned with social standing and affection and human connection, and then a very small part of you that's supposed to be in charge, which is the part of you that is distinctly human and capable of reason and reflection. It's fascinating, Tamara, as you're talking here, I'm again hearing echoes of the work of Sigmund Freud. Indeed, there are echoes of Plato's picture in every world wisdom tradition.
和消费，一个你关心的社会地位、情感和人类联系的部分，然后是一个非常小的、应该负责的部分，也就是你那部分独特的、有能力进行理性和反思的人类部分。塔玛，这太迷人了，当你在这里谈论时，我再次听到了西格蒙德·弗洛伊德工作的回声。确实，在每一个世界智慧传统中都有柏拉图图景的回声。
So Sigmund Freud distinguishes three parts of the human being, which he calls the ego, the super ego, and the id. It doesn't exactly align with Plato's picture. Freud's id is very much aligned with what Plato thinks is the part of the soul that is filled with appetite. But some of what Plato would call the spirited part of the soul might fit into Freud's id. Freud's super ego is the part that roughly corresponds to Plato's reason. And the ego in Freud's picture is its own complicated self. But the idea that you can use some metaphoric description to make sense of human beings and their inner life
所以西格蒙德·弗洛伊德区分了人类的三个部分，他称之为本我、超我和自我。它并不完全与柏拉图的图景一致。弗洛伊德的本我非常符合柏拉图认为的充满欲望的灵魂部分。但柏拉图所称的激情灵魂部分的一些内容可能适合弗洛伊德的本我。弗洛伊德的超我是大致对应柏拉图理性的部分。而弗洛伊德图景中的自我有其自身复杂的自我。但认为你可以使用某种隐喻描述来理解人类及其内心生活
is universal. In the Buddhist tradition, in contrast to speaking of a charioteer and two horses, it's traditional to speak about an elephant and a rider who sits atop the elephant and plays the role of the charioteer. And we, of course, explored the ideas of Danny Kahneman, whose famous book Thinking Fast and Slow, also suggests that we are a house divided, and in fact, we have these different modes of thinking inside our heads. So if you think about the dual processing tradition of which Dan Economan and Amos Varsky are the most famous proponents, what you're getting there is an exact echo of this Buddhist or Platonic picture. Here's the way to think about it. The rider on the Buddha's
是普遍的。在佛教传统中，与谈论战车夫和两匹马相反，传统上谈论的是一头大象和坐在大象背上扮演战车夫角色的骑手。当然，我们探索了丹尼·卡尼曼的思想，他著名的书《思考，快与慢》也表明我们是一个分裂的家庭，事实上，我们头脑中有这些不同的思维模式。所以如果你考虑丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基最著名的双重加工传统，你得到的是这种佛教或柏拉图图景的精确回声。这是思考它的方式。佛陀的骑手
elephant and the charioteer in Plato's metaphor is what Conminen Fersky would call System 2. That's the thinking slow part. And the elephant and Plato's horses and all of our drives and instincts are what common in Fersky would call system one. That is the set of autonomous systems that operate fast. The thinking fast part of ourselves are these horses who just run off in whatever direction they're used to. And the thinking slow part of ourselves is this poor charioteer who's trying to keep the horses in line. So when I'm not returning my shoes,
大象和柏拉图隐喻中的战车夫就是卡尼曼和特沃斯基所说的“系统2”。那是“慢思考”的部分。而大象和柏拉图的马以及我们所有的驱动力和本能就是卡尼曼和特沃斯基所说的“系统1”。也就是那些快速运行的自主系统集合。我们“快思考”的部分就是这些习惯于朝任何方向奔跑的马。而我们“慢思考”的部分就是这个试图让马保持一致的可怜战车夫。所以当我没有退掉我的鞋子时，
the horse, which just wants to run off and do fun things and not go to the post office, is just dashing off in its system one kind of way. And then my little poor rider, which wants to return the shoes, it isn't doing so because my charioteer isn't strong enough to control my horses. That's the story of system one and system two. But notice, this is right there in almost identical metaphoric form in the tradition of ancient Greece and in the tradition of ancient Buddhism. I understand tomorrow that there are resonances here not just to in the works of, you know,
那匹只想跑出去做有趣的事情而不去邮局的马，正以它那种系统1的方式冲出去。然后我那可怜的小骑手，想要退掉鞋子，却没能做到，因为我的战车夫不够强大，无法控制我的马。这就是系统1和系统2的故事。但请注意，这在古希腊传统和古佛教传统中以几乎相同的隐喻形式存在。塔玛，我了解到这里不仅有与……作品的共鸣，
economists and psychologists, but also in the work of modern neuroscientists, looking at how it is the brain comes to have these two different systems inside our heads. Absolutely. So you might think of the idea of system two as being a way of identifying behaviorally something that corresponds to the thought that takes place in the very front of our brain, in the prefrontal cortex. And you might think of system one as the amalgamation of the rest of the things in our brain. It is completely unsurprising that anybody who has thought about human experience over
经济学家和心理学家，还有现代神经科学家的工作，研究大脑是如何在我们头脑中拥有这两个不同系统的。绝对是这样。所以你可以认为系统2的想法是一种在行为上识别出对应于我们大脑最前部、前额叶皮层中发生的思维的方式。你可以认为系统1是大脑中其余事物的集合。任何思考过人类经验的人都完全不感到惊讶
the last 3,000 years has noticed that we are pulled in different directions, given that our brains are accumulated amalgamations of relatively independent systems, each of which is designed to give us particular information about the world. So of course, we are pulled in different directions. The Plato believed that the state of internal division was inevitable and unchangeable? So Plato believed that human flourishing came about by getting
在过去的3000年中，人们注意到我们被拉向不同的方向，因为我们的大脑是相对独立的系统的累积集合，每一个系统都被设计用来给我们关于世界的特定信息。所以当然，我们被拉向不同的方向。柏拉图是否认为这种内部的分裂状态是不可避免且无法改变的？所以柏拉图认为人类的繁荣来自于
your parts aligned. What Plato wanted you to try to do was to train your social horse, that is what he calls your spirited horse, and to train your appetite-driven horse so that they were inclined to follow the commands of reason. Take the story of my returning the shoes or of Leontias rubber necking at the body at the side of the wall of Athens. Plato points out that I'm unhappy with myself when this happens. Leontias is unhappy with himself when that happens. We are in a state where our soul feels divided to us. We feel pulled in different directions.
让你的各个部分保持一致。柏拉图希望你尝试做的是训练你的社会马，也就是他所说的你的激情马，并训练你的欲望驱动的马，使它们倾向于遵循理性的命令。以我退鞋的故事或莱昂提乌斯在雅典城墙边看尸体的故事为例。柏拉图指出，当这种情况发生时，我对我不满意。当这种情况发生时，莱昂提乌斯对自己不满意。我们处于一种灵魂对我们来说感到分裂的状态。我们感到被拉向不同的方向。
What Plato suggests is we are best off when what it is that we want to do and what it is that we're inclined to do coincide. So that you're not fighting against the parts of yourself, you're just moving together in the way that you do when you are doing something that comes naturally. Socrates emphasized the importance of self-knowledge. His student Plato highlighted the need to bring a conflicting inner selves into harmony. But how? One of Plato's students had an idea about this,
柏拉图建议，当我们想要做的事情和我们倾向于做的事情一致时，我们是最好的。这样你就不会与自己的部分作斗争，你只是像做自然而然的事情时那样一起移动。苏格拉底强调了自我知识的重要性。他的学生柏拉图强调了将冲突的内心自我和谐统一的必要性。但如何做到呢？柏拉图的一名学生对此有一个想法，
an idea with many modern echoes. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Yale University, philosopher Tamar Gendler has studied the work of ancient thinkers for clues on how to handle our modern dilemmas. One of these thinkers emphasized the importance of good habits. Tamar, I understand that you had trouble with your balance, so you started working on your balance to the point it has now become something of a habit. You are correct.
一个有许多现代回声的想法。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在耶鲁大学，哲学家塔玛·根德勒研究了古代思想家的作品，寻找如何处理我们现代困境的线索。其中一位思想家强调了良好习惯的重要性。塔玛，我了解到你的平衡有问题，所以你开始练习平衡，以至于它现在已经成为了一种习惯。你是对的。
I, as I entered the decade of life in which I currently find myself, one that starts with the number of fingers that we have on a single hand. I discovered that my balance wasn't as good as it had been previously. So I wanted to make sure that I spent a certain amount of time every day working on my balance. And I had read a lot of the literature on habits and on the way in which when you want to cultivate a new habit, you should chain it to an old habit. And the thing that I do most consistently for two minutes every morning and two minutes every evening is to brush my teeth. I have an electric toothbrush that does 30 seconds four times. So what I started to do was for each 30 seconds segment to stand on one foot while I brushed my teeth. And this ended up having fabulous consequences.
当我进入我目前所处的这个十年生命周期时，一个以我们单手手指数量开头的数字。我发现我的平衡能力不如以前了。所以我确保每天花一定的时间练习平衡。我读了很多关于习惯的文献，以及当你想要培养一个新习惯时，你应该把它与一个旧习惯联系起来。我每天早上和晚上最坚持做两分钟的事情就是刷牙。我有一个电动牙刷，分四次，每次30秒。所以我开始做的是，在每个30秒的时间段里，我一边刷牙一边单脚站立。这最终产生了极好的后果。
One was that actually I practiced standing on one foot for four minutes a day, two minutes on each foot while I was brushing my teeth. But the second thing that happened is that it came to be a cue for me, that when I am holding something in my hand, I should lift one of my feet and stay in balance. And so I noticed that not only do I spend four minutes a day while I brush my teeth standing on one foot in ways that have helped me with my balance. But very often, if I pick up a pen or an umbrella or a small tote bag that I'm holding with my hand, I will lift up one of my feet because it is an over-learned association between
一个是，我实际上每天练习单脚站立四分钟，每只脚两分钟，同时刷牙。但发生的第二件事是，它成为了我的一个暗示，当我手里拿着东西时，我应该抬起一只脚并保持平衡。所以我注意到，不仅我每天刷牙时花四分钟单脚站立，这对我平衡有帮助。而且通常，如果我拿起一支笔、一把雨伞或一个小手提袋，我会抬起一只脚，因为这是一种过度学习的联想，即
holding something in my hand and lifting a foot. Yeah, so it's interesting how these habits at some level, it's precisely because they are on thinking that they're so powerful. One of the things that is extraordinary about the human brain is that it kind of only has one trick, which is follow the easiest pathway, right? In some sense, our brain is like ChachyBT. It's doing the most likely thing, given the configuration of things that have happened before.
手里拿着东西和抬起一只脚之间。是的，所以有趣的是，这些习惯在某种程度上，正是因为它们是“不假思索”的，所以它们才如此强大。人类大脑非凡的一点是，它似乎只有一个技巧，那就是“遵循最简单的路径”，对吧？在某种意义上，我们的大脑就像ChatGPT。它在做最可能的事情，鉴于之前发生的事情的配置。
And so in some really literal sense, the more you do something, the more you are likely to do something. Your brain's job is to minimize its energy expenditure. And the way that it does that is by doing the thing that is relatively easiest, and the thing that is relatively easiest is the thing that it has learned how to do before. That is what it is to learn. Well, of course, standing on one leg when you pick up a pen,
所以从某种字面意义上讲，你做某事越多，你就越有可能做某事。你大脑的工作是最小化其能量消耗。它这样做的方式是做相对最容易的事情，而相对最容易的事情就是它之前学会如何做的事情。这就是学习的意义。好吧，当然，当你拿起笔时单脚站立，
maybe your students will raise an eyebrow at you, but it's perfectly harmless. But you can imagine habits that can have slightly bigger consequences if you're traveling overseas, for example, and you're used to traffic being on one side of the road, and the traffic in the city that you're in is now on the other side of the road, that could have important consequences if you bring the same habits to bear. I spent a bit of time in England last summer, and no matter how many times I said to myself,
也许你的学生会向你挑眉，但这完全无害。但你可以想象，如果你去海外旅行，习惯了交通在道路的一侧，而你所在的城市的交通现在在道路的另一侧，如果你把同样的习惯带过来，那可能会产生稍微大一点的后果。去年夏天我在英国待了一段时间，无论我对自己说了多少次，
they drive on the left. I was repeatedly shocked as I crossed the street by the direction from which cars were coming. And had I tried to sit at the wheel of a vehicle, which of course would have been on the wrong side of the car, I would have found it almost impossible to drive. And one of the things that causes you to realize is how habitual your responses are. So one of Plato's students was very interested in the power of habits. Tell me the story of Aristotle.
他们靠左行驶。当我过马路时，我还是多次被汽车驶来的方向吓到。如果我试图坐在车辆的方向盘后面，当然那会在车的错误一侧，我会发现几乎不可能驾驶。而让你意识到的一件事是你的反应是多么习惯性。所以柏拉图的一名学生对习惯的力量非常感兴趣。告诉我亚里士多德的故事。
So Plato had a student named Aristotle who was in some sense the first encyclopedist. He was the first person to write down everything there was to know about the world around him. So Aristotle collected the constitutions from every city state in the ancient Greek world. Aristotle did all sorts of scientific experiments in physics and biology, collected zoological specimens, and Aristotle also thought about the entire range of philosophical questions that had been raised by his teacher Plato and Plato's teacher Socrates. And he wrote them down in various forms and delivered them to students as lectures. And his views about what it is to live a good life
所以柏拉图有一个学生叫亚里士多德，他在某种意义上是第一位百科全书编纂者。他是第一个写下关于他周围世界所知一切的人。所以亚里士多德收集了古希腊世界每个城邦的宪法。亚里士多德在物理学和生物学方面做了各种科学实验，收集了动物学标本，亚里士多德还思考了由他的老师柏拉图和柏拉图的老师苏格拉底提出的全部哲学问题。他以各种形式写下来，并作为讲座传授给学生。他对什么是美好生活的看法
have survived in an extraordinary volume basically of lecture notes known as the Nikomekian ethics. And in that book Aristotle describes what it takes to be a flourishing human being given all the facts that Aristotle knows. How should human beings live? So Aristotle sums up his view about virtue in a single line in this great work. What does he say tomorrow? He says that virtue is acquired through habit
以一种非凡的讲座笔记卷宗幸存下来，被称为《尼各马可伦理学》。在那本书中，亚里士多德描述了鉴于亚里士多德所知道的所有事实，成为一个繁荣的人类需要什么。人类应该如何生活？所以亚里士多德在这部伟大的作品中用一行字总结了他对美德的看法。塔玛，他说了什么？他说美德是通过习惯获得的
that just as one becomes a harvest by playing the harp, just as one becomes a harpist by playing the harp, just as one becomes a builder by practicing the art of building, so too does one become brave by acting bravely, moderate by acting, moderately, kind by acting kindly. So in other words, if you want to become a particular kind of person, you practice being that kind of person and that's the person you become. Yeah, so what Aristotle is saying is practice, practice, practice, fake it till you make it, you are what you do. You learn what you live. Every poster that you've ever seen in a doctor's office,
就像一个人通过弹竖琴成为竖琴手一样，就像一个人通过练习建筑艺术成为建筑师一样，一个人通过勇敢地行动变得勇敢，通过适度地行动变得适度，通过善良地行动变得善良。所以换句话说，如果你想成为某种特定的人，你就练习成为那种人，那就是你成为的人。是的，所以亚里士多德所说的是练习、练习、练习，假装直到你成功，你就是你所做的。你通过生活来学习。你在医生办公室见过的每一张海报，
that says, children learn what they live, is an example of the Aristotelian lesson that things that we do a lot become things that we do a lot become things that we do naturally. Somewhat more poetically, act as if you already were that which you wish to become. I mean it almost sounds like a totology if we want to turn our beliefs into actions, we need to turn our beliefs into actions, we need to turn our beliefs into actions. It is totalogical if we were unified selves. But the reason that the suggestion is not
那句“孩子在生活中学习”，是亚里士多德教诲的一个例证，即我们经常做的事情会变成我们自然而然做的事情。更具诗意一点的说法是，表现得好像你已经成为了你想成为的那个人。我的意思是，如果我们想把信念转化为行动，这听起来几乎像是一个同义反复，我们需要把信念转化为行动，我们需要把信念转化为行动。如果我们是统一的自我，那确实是同义反复。但这个建议之所以不是
totalogical is because our actions are actually controlled by different aspects of ourselves. And so what Aristotle is saying is, if you want to turn your beliefs into actions, use your beliefs to set up the world in such a way that the actions you undertake accord with your beliefs. So my belief was, my balance will be better if I stand on one foot. I was completely aware that I couldn't think my way into having good balance. I needed to do something with my body. So how did I turn that belief into action? I needed a trick
同义反复，是因为我们的行为实际上是由我们自我的不同方面所控制的。所以亚里士多德的意思是，如果你想把信念转化为行动，就利用你的信念来构建世界，使你所采取的行动与你的信念相一致。所以我的信念是，如果我单脚站立，我的平衡感会更好。我完全意识到，我无法通过思考来获得良好的平衡感。我需要用我的身体做点什么。那么我是如何将那个信念转化为行动的呢？我需要一个技巧
for using my belief system to cause my body to practice the thing that it needed to practice. And so the trick was to find a two-minute segment during which I would remember to do the thing that I intended to do and that I would never reason not to do it. And it would be a short enough amount of time that I would have the self-control to do it. So it's not technological because you start by doing it self-consciously and you end up doing it automatically. So in some ways what you're saying is that a habit is a sort of tool for turning the things that we ought to do or that we want to do or we'd like to do into the things that we ought to do, or that we want to do, or we'd like to do,
来利用我的信念系统，促使我的身体去练习它需要练习的东西。所以这个技巧就是找到一个两分钟的时间段，在这期间我会记得去做我打算做的事情，而且我永远不会找理由不去这样做。这段时间足够短，我有自控力去完成它。所以这不是同义反复，因为你开始时是自觉地去做，最后却变成了自动地去做。所以从某种程度上说，你是在说，习惯是一种工具，用来把我们应该做、想要做或乐意做的事情，变成我们应该做、想要做或乐意做的事情，
into the things that we actually do do. That's exactly right. Habits are tools for turning aughts into isis. But habits are indifferent between aughts and aughts. So I made a very nice habit that I like, which is that when I brush my teeth, I stand on one foot. But I also made a habit that I don't like very much,
变成我们实际去做的事情。完全正确。习惯是将“应该”转化为“现实”的工具。但习惯对于“应该”和“不应该”是无差别的。所以我养成了一个我喜欢的很好的习惯，那就是刷牙时单脚站立。但我也养成了一个我不太喜欢的习惯，
which is when I see my phone with a number next to any one of the little icons on it, I push on that icon to see what has caused that red circle with a number on it to appear. And I do that even when, on reflection, I would rather be in a conversation with the person across the table from me. So it's just as easy to build a habit to do something that you would like to be doing as it is to build a habit to do something that you would not like to be doing. Each is easy to acquire, each is hard to extend. So to go back to the metaphor of the the writer and
那就是当我看到手机上某个小图标旁边有数字时，我会点击那个图标，看看是什么导致了那个带有数字的红色圆圈出现。即使在反思时，我宁愿与坐在桌子对面的人交谈，我也会这样做。所以，养成一个你想做的习惯，和养成一个你不想做的习惯一样容易。两者都容易养成，也都难以戒除。回到柏拉图给我们的那个关于驭者和
the two horses that Plato gave us, you said before that Aristotle's idea was that rather than instruct the writer, the idea here is to tame the horses. Aristotle's idea is exactly that you need to tame the horses. Imagine you're trying to tell your cat to stay off the couch. You can't talk to your cat and say, I'm sorry, Tyroneus, whatever kind of name your cat has. You are not permitted on the couch. That doesn't work. You need to tele-cat what to do by associating certain kinds of actions
两匹马的隐喻，你之前说过亚里士多德的想法是，与其指导驭者，不如驯服马匹。亚里士多德的想法正是你需要驯服马匹。想象一下，你试图告诉你的猫不要上沙发。你不能跟你的猫说话，说：“对不起，泰罗纽斯（不管你的猫叫什么名字），你不准上沙发。”那没用。你需要通过将某些行为与
with certain kinds of consequences. If you get on the couch, there will be a loud noise that you don't like. Same with our inner selves. I can draw a parabolic design to tell you where a ball is going to come if you throw it towards my catchers' mitt. But talking to the charioteer that is drawing me a parabola is not helpful in training my hand to catch the ball and not helpful in training my face to pull itself out of the line of fire as the ball is coming towards it. So Aristotle's point is how do you train yourself to stand on one foot? You don't talk to your foot. You stand on one foot. How do you train your cat to stay off the couch?
某些后果联系起来，来告诉猫该怎么做。如果你上了沙发，就会有你不喜欢的巨大噪音。我们内在的自我也是如此。我可以画一个抛物线设计来告诉你，如果你把球扔向我的接球手套，球会落到哪里。但是，与那个正在为我画抛物线的驭者交谈，对于训练我的手去接球毫无帮助，对于训练我的脸在球飞过来时避开火线也毫无帮助。所以亚里士多德的观点是，你如何训练自己单脚站立？你不是跟你的脚说话。你就是单脚站立。你如何训练你的猫不要上沙发？
You don't talk to your cat, you make it unpleasant for your cat to be on the couch. How do you train yourself to catch a ball? You don't model the parabolic structure, you hold up your hand until it becomes instinctive. Learning how to type, learning how to do anything routine and automatic, is training Plato's horses. Tamara, you say that for Aristotle, another key to forming virtuous habits was the practice of moderation. What did he mean by this? So Aristotle thinks all virtues are moderate intermediates between two extremes. Take the example of bravery. So to be brave is certainly not to be cowardly, but it's also
你不是跟你的猫说话，而是让它待在沙发上变得不愉快。你如何训练自己接球？你不是去模拟抛物线结构，而是举起手直到它变成本能。学习打字，学习做任何常规和自动的事情，都是在训练柏拉图的马。塔玛拉，你说对于亚里士多德来说，形成美德习惯的另一个关键是中庸之道。他这是什么意思？亚里士多德认为所有的美德都是两个极端之间的适度中间点。以勇敢为例。勇敢当然不是懦弱，但它也
not to be reckless. It's to be brave at the right time in the right way. Likewise, says Aristotle, to be generous is not to be selfish, but it's also not to be extravagant. To be generous is to give the right amount at the right time in the right way. Aristotle thinks this is true for every virtue. So it's quite clear that with Socrates and Plato, they were echoes in modern psychology, modern thinking, modern literature. What are the echoes and resonances you're seeing an Aristotle's work in modern psychological science, modern brain science.
不是鲁莽。它是在正确的时间以正确的方式勇敢。同样，亚里士多德说，慷慨不是自私，但也不是挥霍。慷慨是在正确的时间以正确的方式给予适量的东西。亚里士多德认为这对每一种美德都是如此。所以很明显，苏格拉底和柏拉图的思想在现代心理学、现代思想和现代文学中都有回响。你在现代心理科学和现代脑科学中看到了亚里士多德作品的哪些回响和共鸣？
The scientific insights that lie at the heart of the entire contemporary discussion of habit are the scientific insights that lie at the heart of what Aristotle is saying. That is what we practice is what we become. Notice that that's not just true in the contemporary literature on habit, of which there are numerous examples. You cannot go to an airport without being confronted with a set of books about habits, seven habits of highly effective people, various books that are going to tell you how to get micro habits, macro habits. But if you think about a second meaning of the word habit, it's a term that we use to describe the uniform that is worn by someone religious. that is worn by someone religious. And you might think that one of the great insights
处于当代习惯讨论核心的科学见解，正是亚里士多德所言核心的科学见解。那就是我们练习什么，我们就会成为什么。请注意，这不仅在关于习惯的当代文献中是真实的，其中有无数的例子。你走进机场，必然会看到一系列关于习惯的书，比如《高效能人士的七个习惯》，以及各种告诉你如何养成微习惯、宏习惯的书。但如果你思考一下“习惯”（habit）这个词的第二个含义，它也是我们用来描述宗教人士所穿的服装的术语。你可能会认为宗教传统最伟大的见解之一
of religious traditions is to instill in us certain kinds of habits. I was raised in the Jewish tradition, and one of the things that the Jewish tradition wants to instill in people is a habit of expressing gratitude. And so it is a rule in Judaism. Whenever I am handed a piece of food, I recite a blessing that notes how it is that that food comes into being. That is, I need to stop for a minute and think, does it grow on a vine? Does it grow from the tree?
就是向我们灌输某种习惯。我在犹太传统中长大，犹太传统想要向人们灌输的一件事就是表达感恩的习惯。因此，在犹太教中有一条规则。每当我拿到食物时，我都会背诵一段祝福，指出这种食物是如何产生的。也就是说，我需要停下来想一想，它是长在藤蔓上的吗？它是从树上长出来的吗？
Does it come from the earth? How does this food come about? And it becomes habitual that every act of eating is associated with an act of gratitude. Medieval monasteries are structured in such a way that what you do is habitually built into the rhythm of your life. The practice of wearing a wristband that says, WWJD, is to create in you a habit. At any moment where I'm trying to figure out what the right thing to do is, I should check what would Jesus do.
它是来自大地吗？这种食物是怎么来的？于是，每一次进食都与感恩的行为联系在一起，这变成了习惯。中世纪的修道院结构就是这样，你所做的事情习惯性地融入了你生活的节奏中。佩戴写有“WWJD”（耶稣会怎么做）的腕带，是为了在你心中养成一种习惯。在任何我试图弄清楚什么是正确做法的时刻，我都应该检查一下耶稣会怎么做。
And I would say virtually everything that I say and do is shaped by my meta-awareness, that the reasons that I seem to be doing something may not be the reasons that I'm actually doing it, that I am pulled in different directions, and that I do what I find easy. So, every day I am presented with multiple opportunities to realign anything from a tiny habit? Where I put my keys to a major habit. How often do I talk to my kids on the phone
我会说，我所说和所做的几乎每一件事，都受到我的元意识的影响，即我似乎在做某事的理由可能并不是我实际做这件事的理由，我被不同的方向拉扯，我做我发现容易的事情。所以，每一天我都有多次机会来重新调整任何事情，从一个小习惯（我把钥匙放在哪里）到一个大习惯（我多久给孩子们打一次电话）
so that it is part of the rhythm of my life? What happens when despite our best efforts to build our lives right, things don't break our way? When we are victims of unfairness, illness or tragedy. Turns out, the ancients struggled with these conundrums too. In our companion piece to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, Tamar Gendler explores what we should do when we are confronted by Bad Luck, and also how we can change our luck. If you are already a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, you can listen to that episode now.
使它成为我生活节奏的一部分？当我们尽了最大努力去正确地构建生活，但事情却不尽如人意时会发生什么？当我们成为不公、疾病或悲剧的受害者时？事实证明，古人也曾与这些难题作斗争。在我们本期节目的配套文章中（仅供 Hidden Brain Plus 订阅者使用），塔玛·根德勒探讨了当我们面对厄运时应该怎么做，以及我们如何改变运气。如果你已经是 Hidden Brain Plus 的订阅者，你现在就可以收听那一集。
It's titled, What Homer and Epic Teedis Can Teach Us Today. If you haven't subscribed yet, you can check it out for free on a seven day trial. To do so, go to apple.co-slash-hiddenbrain on your phone. Again, that's apple.co-slash-hiddenbrain. Your support helps us to build more episodes like this one and keeps the show thriving. Tamar, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Tomar Gendler is a philosopher at Yale University and the dean of the faculty of Arts and Sciences.
它的标题是《荷马和伊壁鸠鲁今天能教给我们什么》。如果你还没有订阅，可以在七天免费试用期内查看。要这样做，请在手机上访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。再说一遍，是 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你的支持帮助我们制作更多像这样的节目，并让节目蓬勃发展。塔玛，非常感谢你今天参加 Hidden Brain。谢谢。塔玛·根德勒是耶鲁大学的哲学家，也是文理学院的院长。
If you have follow-up questions about today's conversation that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please email them to us. Record a short voice memo, one to two minutes is plenty, and send it to ideasathydenbrain.org. Use the subject line, wisdom. Again, that email address is ideasathydenbrain.org. And thanks. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen
如果你对今天的对话有后续问题，并且愿意与 Hidden Brain 的听众分享，请通过电子邮件发送给我们。录制一段简短的语音备忘录，一到两分钟就足够了，发送到 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“wisdom”。再说一遍，电子邮件地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。谢谢。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括 Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy Paul、Kristen
Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbrick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick 和 Nick Woodbrick。Tara Boyle 是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。